it is friday and that means it's time
for
friday follies and for that we turn to
fox news contributor raymond arroyo all
right raymond there have been a series
of
under reported bombs this week yeah lord
starting with a pretty high profile one
michelle obama's group when we all vote
held their big culture of democracy
summit it was sort of a star-studded get
out the vote effort before the midterms
it featured nicole hannah jones the
creator of the 1619 project comedians
and actors now they claim it was a
non-partisan event
i'll let you draw your own ingram
conclusions
this is not me saying this this is
scholars of democracy have been armed
we've seen letters published with more
than 100 scholars of democracy that say
that our democracy is in peril last year
for the first time we were listed as a
democracy in decline you all know what
i'm talking about we wanted to see those
condoms i i have
friends who
uh they never wrote about
politics or i was shocked that they
weren't even registered and then i was
like okay i get it you're you're a
straight white guy that's all an
election is
i'm not giving you my power i'm lending
you my power for the period of time
you're in office to do my bidding laura
it was a totally non-partisan event
really
first of all it's aggressively boring
okay it seems like it's like an old
throwback to 2012 or something it
doesn't it doesn't exactly speak to the
issues of the day in any
manner
and then the non-partisanship continued
with the hostess and founders michelle
obama
if you don't vote
other people will in this country we
tell ourselves that every vote counts
that every
voice matters
then we hear about harsh new voting
restrictions
getting passed in georgia
then we hear about another law in texas
we tell ourselves that our grocery
stores won't get shot up by a white
supremacist that my kids will be able to
read tony morrison in english class i
don't know about you but i am tired
we've got to take a long hard look at
how
we can make congress itself better
that means changing the filibuster if
that's what it takes to save our
democracy totally nonpartisan laura even
selena gomez who introduced michelle
obama couldn't scare up a crowd the
turnout was underwhelming when michelle
and a lineup of celebrities can't turn
democrats out nelly the midterms are
going to be rocky this is the canary in
the coal mine for them i know this is
really kind of a follow-on from the
angle raymond like when they're losing
they say democracy is in peril right so
they're going to lose and so when they
lose you're going to say oh see
democracy doesn't work what
it's such a ridiculous argument you also
can't get americans to focus on the
things you're interested in abortion
rights and january 6th when they're
suffering from the things they're
interested in and you're offering no
solutions let me let me take it a step
further you can't really get americans
to empathize with your message about how
angry you are
when you're doing it from maui from
martha's vineyard and from you know l.a
beverly hills yeah beverly hills okay so
that's if you're angry in those places
and uh okay laura speaking of bombs
ripley's believe it or not unveiled
their joe
biden and kamala harris wax figures at
one of their parks in tennessee months
ago
well but the internet just discovered
these uh figures i'll let you take a
look believe it or not that's joe and
kamala first of all joe biden looks like
matthew modine in uh stranger things
and kamala harris is unrecognizable good
lord looks like one of the damon
brothers movies i mean who are they
trying to capture there you know this
thing's as far off as that lucy statue
that showed up a few years ago looks
nothing like kamala harris i hope she
didn't see this wax figure that's all i
can say
how dare they how dare they
wow yeah let's hope she doesn't take a
look at that wagon raymond first of all
a bad guy i rudely i rudely interrupted
you because i i knew i was like i'm
gonna forget what i was gonna say
it looks like biden in real life because
biden looks like a wax figure
you know yes he's had so much filler in
botox or whatever the heck that is in
his face that it just it doesn't even
move with the motion is he running is he
running to the next election where is he
going with that he has to remember he
has to do that little spring in his step
to look like he's really vital right he
has to do that thing laura finally two
canadian students have created something
that i think it's a bomb you may not
this is for people who want to share the
bed with their dogs
the dog won't sleep on your bed you'll
sleep in his it's a new human-sized dog
bed it's called pluffle
which got me thinking who would ever use
this my kids
nico would use it nico no no take a look
okay
i think our phone i found the ultimate
birthday present for you now i think
it's a bad idea i don't even want the
dogworth's allergens in my bed so i'm
certainly not crawling into theirs but i
can see you in that in that well i have
been known to fall asleep in the dog bed
but my kids a couple times um i like
those pj's by the way um and niko
freedom matters always does that yeah we
got to get the freedom matters so
the pj's going raymond i know you like
you like it when maddie your little rat
terrier comes up to sleep on the bed i
know you love that she's now so old she
can't leap up so we just leave her on
the floor now unless your dog happens to
be clifford no one needs this bed laura
i'm sorry all right raymond well i'm not
buying now i have an idea for every
holiday gift-giving option happy
birthday by the way to you
thank you very much raymond we won't say
which one i'll see you soon thank you